-We are so happy
to have Fred Armisen
back with us all week.
How you doing, Fred?
-Great.
-Fred, I'm always amazed
that you have time
not just to lead this band
and be an actor
and a comedian and musician,
but also all these
other side projects.
And I was thrilled to hear
that you are starting
your own food truck.
-I am.
-That's so great.
-I'm so happy about it.
So...
-I can tell
you're happy about it.
-Yeah, I'm so glad.
-Sometimes I can tell
when you're being insincere,
but I feel the happiness
is just --
-It's called
the Jingle Bells food truck.
-Okay.
-And so we just have, like --
It's like a lot
of jingling bells,
you know,
like the classic Christmas --
-Gotcha, so when the truck
moves, it's pretty loud?
-It's pretty loud. Yeah.
And then when we arrive at,
you know, a site,
we'll just, you know,
ring those bells some more.
And there's no, like,
food, per se,
but it's more of the sort of act
of having a food truck,
because I think what people like
is the actual vehicle...
-Oh, funny.
-...and sort of coming around.
-See, I'm gonna take
the other side of this.
I think people like
the food the most.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
Like, I think when you think
about, "Oh, you want to go --"
I think if a friend
of mine said,
"You want to go
to this new food truck?"
I'd be pretty bummed
if it was just a truck.
-Interesting. Okay.
-Yeah.
-I mean, what do you do --
Like, you still walk
to the truck anyway, don't you?
Like, you walk to food trucks.
-I would walk to the truck
with the expectation
that there would be food.
-But if -- Not as an argument,
but if you heard bells,
right, if you heard
jingle bells, you would go.
-I would -- Yes, I would go.
-You would go.
-But then I would be angry
when I got there.
That's the part --
I feel like you're thinking
all the way up to the moment.
Everything would be
happy anticipation.
I'm hearing bells.
I see a food truck.
I walk over.
Yes, we are on the same page
up to that moment.
-Yes, but --
-Now we get up there
and I look in --
I'm assuming there's a door,
like the window you lean in
to see what the food is.
-Yeah, but we don't
live in that moment.
We live in the moment before.
We're not in that business.
It's the moment before.
-You say, "We're not
in that business."
I don't know
what the business is.
-It's a food truck.
-No, it's not a food --
-It is.
[ Laughter ]
-Give it up for Fred Armisen,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]